Kenneth Silverman author of lightning
man the accursed life of Samuel FB
Morris why was it a cursed
well Morse felt that everything he
accomplished and he accomplished a lot
boomeranged on him it all came back at
with some bad result he could never have
some kind of success without it being
followed by some failures and disaster
this cover has this photo on it which
you say in the book is about at age 60
who was he and what did he accomplish
well very briefly I mean Morse's family
thought that he was fickle that he moved
around from one thing to another and in
fact he accomplished a lot of things and
moved into a lot of places he was an
important painter he was an important
inventor he was an important politician
and he was a pioneer photographer what
did he paint well he painted portraits
to support himself and to support his
family but he hated doing that I mean it
was considered sort of the lowest branch
of painting what he wanted to do with
these large historical canvases like
Raphael's the School of Athens you know
that shows Socrates and Plato and and
everybody else and he he tried to do
that to get away from traveling around
itinerant as an itinerant portrait
painter Samuel FB Mora stands for Samuel
Finley Brees Moore's the Finley came
from his mother's family his grandfather
his mother's father was the President of
Princeton what did he invent Morse he's
best known for of course the let's call
it the American electromagnetic
Telegraph I am I'm being that precise
because there were other Telegraph's
around that were invented independently
of Morse others that didn't work by
electromagnetism others that weren't
American but the Telegraph that we know
the Telegraph that became the Western
Union Telegraph sort of the world
standard that was really Morse's
invention what did he teach well he he
taught at NY New York University he was
hired as the first professor of Fine
Arts in the country and he had a studio
in the new york university building
where he taught painting it happened
though that in the same studio he was
always putting teeth also putting
together his first Telegraph and I had
wire stretched around the room and his
frames and on so on also in the same
studio he began doing photography at New
York University and he put up a
photography studio on top of the
building and was taking portraits of
prominent New Yorkers he had a lot going
on at the same time when was he a
politician well he was a politician all
of his life I mean Morris was a profound
cultural nationalist I mean he had a
very strong sense of identity
identification with the revolutionary
generation I mean his his great heroes
were Washington and Lafayette and you
know the those people of the late 18th
century in America and he that please
repeat the question yeah I just when he
was a politics when he ran for office
yes
oh well throughout his life I mean he
ran twice for mayor of New York he ran
once for his district congressional
district in Poughkeepsie New York and
people wanted him to run for president
but he declined
did he ever win he always lost badly oh
no no not necessarily because of his
politics but horse
despite his you know great
sophistication and invention and
painting and everything else many ways a
very naive person and certainly very
naive but when it came to hardball
politics and for instance in one New
York mayoral tea race I think the wig
some wigs published a notice in the
newspaper assigned by him by Moore
saying that he had withdrawn from the
race and this was the day before the
election so he ended up with about 50
votes I think at a and James Fenimore
Cooper said who was a friend of his said
well he would have won the election if
he had had another 15,000 votes now he
had no kind of sense of how to deal I
think on this level with you people you
know sort of tough practical people how
did you get interested in him
oh well I write biography and I look as
I looked back over things I've been
trying to do a kind of National Portrait
Gallery of people who I think of as
representative figures in American
culture I have a minister Cotton Mather
micro topography of I have a poet Edgar
Allen Poe who I wrote a biography of
have an entertainer Harry Houdini who
ever heard of boundary and now I'm
trying to do an inventor here as a
different sort of figure the there was
also the fact that there hadn't been a
biography of Morris for about 60 years
and that was another attraction and also
I was very attracted to the huge amount
of information that existed about Morse
I mean here in Washington I'm in the
National the Smithsonian Institution in
the Library of Congress as thousands and
thousands of letters Museum of American
history or has the fabulous Western
Union collection on telegraphy on the
Telegraph I like to work with a lot of
material you know and I don't like to
work with materialists care so that was
another big attraction where do you live
well he was born in Iran where do you
live oh I live in New York City
how long have you lived there
sixty-eight years and what I was born in
New York City and what have you done
most of your life
well mostly I've taught at New York
University I took American literature
and some American history my interest
has always been Lily in American culture
and how long you've been writing these
biographies well that depends I mean I
wrote a book on the American Revolution
went 35 years or so ago which was also
very biographical I mean it was it's
called a cultural history of the
American Revolution and it followed the
careers of painters like Benjamin West
and John Singleton Copley and poets like
Philip Freneau and actors and dancers
and musicians during the Revolution see
what they were doing my sort of a thesis
of it was that during the Revolutionary
period there came into existence for the
first time a really a sort of American
artistic culture and I in sort of
illustrating that I follow the careers
of painters and
dancers and so on so it's very
biographical so I feel I've always been
writing biography of my whole
professional life this is a
self-portrait you say of Samuel FB
Morris back in 1811 1812
why do artists do the self-portraits hmm
interesting
well it's not so easy I guess to get a
model I mean you're there you look at
yourself in the mirror and sketch
yourself I don't I don't know another I
don't know another explanation maybe
there is one where did you say in the
book he was born in 1791 lived for 80
years where was he born he was born in
Charlestown Massachusetts his father was
the minister of the First Congregational
Church in Charlestown one of the oldest
churches Congregational churches in
America Moore says a a long background
in New England Calvinist Protestantism
what was his father's name his father
was jedidiah morse and was very well
known we we don't know his name so well
and and another we know Samuel FB
warrants his name so well e-either them
but his father was he's referred to as
the father of American geography in
addition to preaching at the church and
being one of the leading ministers in
America he produced the first American
geographies and it was said that every
American house had three books they had
a Webster spelling but that a Bible that
had a Webster spelling book and they had
one of Jedediah Morris's geographies his
mother well his mother as I mentioned
was the daughter of the President of
Princeton University he was a very sharp
witted very tart woman I mean very very
smart and she she didn't she said what
she thought including a better son
Samuel you say that they called him
Finley and the early part of his life is
that did they use that all of his life
no I think he wanted really to be Morris
I mean his father was very well known
his father had dined with George
Washington his father knew everybody in
the country is father had a large
reputation and he I think Samuel always
wanted to have that
sort of reputation for himself and to be
more he for him to be the Morse but you
say I mean the first name was Finley for
a long time to change to Samuel it was a
sort of nickname you know like Buster or
something it's the childhood childhood
making although people close to him
remember his first wife I think still
called him Finley where did he go to
school he went to Yale well first he'd
go into Phillips Academy as a young as a
boy and then went to Yale as his father
had gone and his father Jedediah was a
Yale trustees and all the boys went to
Yale he had two brothers - where did he
meet his wife and this is a that he drew
this portrait everyone yes that's a
portrait of Lucretia he was in his
itinerary he was traveling around from
town to town setting up as a itinerant
portrait painter and advertised and you
know come and I'll do a portrait of you
and he met her was a New Hampshire but
no as he was painting on one of his
portrait tours and back to his mother
and father for a while because they play
a role in the book how many brothers did
he have he had two brothers it had been
a very large family
oh it is astonishing to me I think they
lost something like nine children I
think the he had had nine other brothers
and sisters all died and Richard and
Sidney played a role in his life how
much of a role a huge role Sidney was a
very respected newspaper editor in
nineteenth-century America I mean he was
the publisher and editor of the
best-known I suppose religious journal
in the country the New York Observer I
mean it had very big subscriptions very
prosperous Sidney was able to buy a
newspaper office building on Nassau
Street I think it was in New York and
for a while Richard brother Richard also
worked with the the New York Observer
although Richard rather like Samuel
seems to have been afflicted with the
family gremlins I mean he was very
depressed guy he were Richard always
wandering around and searching for some
kind of relief from his heavy
heartedness and on generally unable to
settle down
but Morse kept in very close touch with
his brothers for his whole life how many
children did he have Sango Morris he had
three children by his first marriage and
again I think two died in infants two
others died in infancy and then I
believe it's never cool for I think
while his second marriage in the back of
the book you list a whole bunch of
illustrations and art that you have in
the book one of those in there that we
have spent some time capturing on video
is the one that's right here in
Washington and it's called house
representatives what what role did that
particular painting play in his life
well it's a wonderful painting I mean
it's I just say at the Corcoran Gallery
he worked on and my recollection is that
he worked on it for almost a year this
is the kind of painting nortz really
wanted to do by the way on the screen it
didn't mean her up that's the old
executive office in the White House
that's the cork when you just mentioned
and we're gonna go inside and show the
audience in a moment the actual painting
in some detail go ahead I didn't mean
interact well he worked on it for I
think really almost a year he was given
a room in con Congress and the people
were fair the representatives were very
helpful they came in and sat for him in
the mornings and I think all together he
painted if I'm I think the numbers
correct 68 portraits in this painting
it's a very very very ambitious 68
members 68 members 68 members of
Congress yes and because they do have a
you know a list of all the people that
are in this this painting is at the
Corcoran but public can go in and look
at it that's the old House of
Representatives which is now called it
the statuary hall over in the Congress
have you been have you seen this
portrait itself yes you know I I mean
I'm very very fond of it in many ways in
addition to the members of Congress well
he has this whatever guy lighting the
the great lamp there the great
chandelier
others of the members of the Supreme
Court are there some reporters are there
his father is the air Jedediah Morris
and the Moores worked on it for a very
very long time and very very hard it was
very tricky in other ways too the
lighting is tricky the architecture is
very tricky heat he worked again did
sketch after sketch trying to get this
vaulted ceiling correct and this is this
is what he wanted to be as an artist
it's a very very nationalistic painting
I think I mean it's a commemoration of
America you say that the the Congress
gave him a room for four months and
where he can do this work
did they pay him anything to do this
that's a good question
I don't know I don't think so the the
painting while he was working on it had
a lot of publicity in Washington though
I mean it'll cut into the press and
people followed if they wanted to know
you know who he was painting next and
how far along he was it got him a lot of
notice in each of the members the 68
members that he captured in the painting
sit for a portrait themselves I think
that they did I believe that's true
I think so Morris he did most of the
work in Washington and then took this
large canvas I think it's something like
80 square feet maybe 80 square feet took
it back to New Haven where his father
was living to to complete it by the way
this was shot by Jamie sides of our
c-span group and it's done with
available light there are no special
lights put in that room and these shots
these very close-up shots can't give you
this sense of how big it is it covers
that whole wall there you have the
people and the shot so you can see how
big it is you say that he was displayed
in many cities but didn't make a dime
didn't make a dime lost him money I was
taken to New England and put on display
it was taken to New York and put in on
display lost money but not only didn't
make money lost money various
explanations I mean that when it was in
New York he thought
competition you know from whatever the
circus from other exhibitions and so on
that's what I meant it's one of the
things I meant in Kolding Morse's life
accurs'd I mean here was his greatest
effort today it I mean this is the early
1820s I think and he I think he felt he
felt the painting had ruined him he it's
he had invested all his talent in it he
had given it his you know his best
abilities and it went absolutely nowhere
you learn early in your book that he was
a very outspoken anti-catholic why well
of course you know as given it Morse's
Congregationalist background you know in
in in the 1660s in the Puritan boston
when the pope has appendicitis his front
face to page news in the press I mean
it's partly just the old you know
Calvinist Congregationalist antipathy to
Catholicism but Moore's also spent time
in Italy I mean he Italy was a great
training ground for painters he had been
preceded there by people like Benjamin
West and you know there was nothing to
see in America there were no great
paintings really around for an artist to
to look at you wanted to see great art
he went to do Italy or to France Morris
went there I think really I think spent
two years and loved loved the art I mean
saw everything was just overwhelmed by
what he saw at the same time I thought
that of the the omnipresence of
Catholicism had destroyed the country I
mean people the streets were full of
beggars everything was dirty he blamed
it all on the church not only that but
he well there was one episode when Morse
was it was a celebration of the host
that Morris attended and he was standing
on the street when a kind of canopy came
down the street with the host underneath
it and everybody watching took off their
hats and bowed or made a sign of the
Cross or something and Morris was taking
notes and kept his hat on
and when the host passed the soldier
came up to him and started cursing him
out and then knocked his hat off with
the butter is rifle that's that's an
episode more it's never forgot and he
keeps repeating it in one political
tract after another that as he as he saw
it Catholicism was a religion of force
this is as opposed to let's
Protestantism where you heard sermons
you know your reason was appealed to all
had made kept people in line and
Catholicism was guns and he brought this
back to America and camp became a leader
of American nativism and wrote and spoke
constantly and very loudly against
Catholic immigration to America
matter of fact you right he says like
actors speaking their parts worship
worshippers at Mass mal the words of
priests priests he often caught yawning
and his rushed rushed inarticulate
recitation of the Latin prayers struck
him variously and these are in quotes as
whining drawling brawling and gurgling
indeed the Playhouse was but the secular
offspring of the church a daughter this
prolific mother of abominations and a
child of worthy of its damned how could
somebody and we'll talk later about his
position on slavery which he was for you
say how could somebody so Christian
supposedly in quotes hate so the
Catholics as much as he did well of
course I mean nativism you know in
America in the 1830s and 40s this is
pretty widespread I mean the nativist
candidates did pretty well in local and
state elections and of the 1830s and 40s
there was a lot of fear of immigration a
you know a you know I we can understand
that I think our ourselves now from the
point of view of 9/11 or the you know
the French or having some some worries
like this to the Morse's thought and was
that the church really intended to
topple an American government and really
to take it over people you know in the
1830s were still not far from the war of
1812 the British had come into Boston
you know I come into Washington burn the
Capitol the French in the Spanish
government still had various designs in
the early 19th century on America and
Mexico and so on the idea that things
were brewing in Europe to to take over
of the government to come back to
restore monarchism or something like
that in America's it's very close to the
thinking to review where we've been he
was born in 1791 in Charlestown
Massachusetts is that right outside of
Boston yes just of course the bay there
he finished the pain that we looked at
in 1822 was he was he making any money
he's in his 30s along the way here is he
is he making he's married not making any
money he says why are they living
together
no that was anyway that's the most
difficult part of Maura's life that
itinerant portrait painting kept him on
the road and his apart from his family
apart from his children for when he went
to paint in Charleston she'd set South
Carolina she did stay with him for a
while but otherwise she and the children
were there and either in New Haven or
somewhere in New England and he was on
the road 1837 the panic of 1837 the
depression how big a depression was it
and what impact did it have on his life
well he had had a very good year in
Charleston South Carolina the year
before he went back in 1837 38 and
actually he did fairly well the other
painters in Charleston he found was
starving but the the depression that hit
Charleston - in it yes it lowered his
even though he hated doing portraits he
was doing them in making some money but
now it was hard to even get commissions
for portraits how did he get into the
electromagnetic Telegraph business you
know that's that's it that's a good one
that's a tough one actually as a student
at Yale he had he'd like science and
Yale had one of the best science
departments probably the best science
department in the country and he had
attended some at college he had attended
some demonstrations on electricity that
fascinated him
and one demonstration as I recall the
students held hands and why the first
student was given an electric shock and
it went through all of them holding
hands and he spent a summer working in
is called the Natural History cabinet at
Yale doing some some kind of
experimentation he had also done some
invention with his brother they invented
a flexible pump excuse me a flexible
piston for pumps that could be used for
fire engines or garden hoses the the
idea of invention and an interest in
science and electricity was there pretty
early what brought it to the stage of
wanting to invent the Telegraph it's a
complicated story apparently he was
coming back from France and what a team
is this 1830 or no and there was some
talk about sending electrical current
among the passengers and whether that
current could be sent instantaneously
across a long wire according to Moore's
that gave him the idea that if if that
was true if a current could be sent
instantaneously away it might be
possible to send messages by electricity
and according to him as soon as he got
home he started working on the problem
in his artists artist studio in New York
University and put together his first
Telegraph but that ships name was sully
the slowly that that turned out to be a
controversial trip very very
controversial why well another
passenger honest Sully Charles name
Charles Jackson dr. Charles Jackson who
was a geologist and physician with
interest in science and also interest
some interest in the arts he later
claimed that it was he who gave on the
Sully trip who gave Morse the idea for
the Telegraph and who said well if you
can send a like electricity
instantaneously through a wire it should
be possible to send messages and in fact
as soon as Morse brought out his first
Telegraph's
Charles Jackson threatened him in all
kinds of way with exposure challenged
him as the inventor of the Telegraph and
so on Charles Jackson is not someone
you'd like to believe though for one
thing he later also claimed to have
discovered anaesthetic he was a doctor
and he was only 28 years old on that
voyage if I remember right he was young
going but Morris was in his 40s right so
he the name Leonard Gail who he started
working with in 1836 who was he
Leonard Gail was a professor of physics
at New York University when worst at his
first Telegraph's they were not strong I
mean one of the problems was he could
send a an impulse through say 40 feet of
wire Howard if this thing was going to
succeed it obviously needed to be sent
through much longer distances Leonard
Gail was himself interested in magnetism
and he understood first of all that
instead of winding the wire around the
horseshoe magnet a few times loosely as
Morse had done what was needed was to
wrap it tightly a lot of times that that
would increase the the transmission
power he also understood that Morse was
using a battery that as I guess was
nitric acid and a couple of metal plates
then he needed a much more powerful
battery and Gail and put together from
Morse I think was a battery as I recall
with several more cups to it a cups of
nitric acid that was a huge boost for
Morse's Telegraph and instead of sending
it 40 feet he was sending messages than
whatever 1,500 2,000 feet something like
that so Gail helped him very much put it
in context of anybody in the world
communicating on a telegraph at that
time at that time yes but very very
different kinds of Telegraph's not not
what you think of as Telegraph very
complicated devices sending
impulses short distances
impractical really nothing that could be
used what the marsh code also plays in
this what is the Morris code well when
were started off in its earliest
telegraph he used an alphabetical code a
numerical code that is the
strange-looking but his machine his
first telegraph produced a set of V's on
a tape and there would be say 3 vs
followed by two V's and that would then
the number would be 32 and you would
have to then look in a dictionary for
number 32 and that would be the word
being sent say was spoon then on the
tape he would say there would be six V's
followed by two V's followed by 5yz that
would be word 625 and you lucked up in
this huge dictionary that Morse prepared
this huge sized refrigerator and at 625
and that would be windmill or whatever
it was he gradually refined all of that
and then started developing his famous
dot-dash code sending not v's but dots
and dashes representing not numbers but
letters of the alphabet there's been a
lot of controversy about that because
one of horses associates Alfred Vail
fail himself didn't claim that he had
invented the quote Morse code but later
descendants of Vail and associates avail
claim that it really was his invention I
don't think so I mean it seems to me
pretty clear that works himself invented
the the Morse code here is Vail on the
screen right now a photograph of him
where did he meet him bill was a student
at New York University he had just
graduated and he had seen some of
Morse's demonstrations of his Telegraph
at New York University and was very
interested in it and Morse was drawn to
him because Vail was an experienced
recall at I mean Val's family had a
machine shop in Morristown New Jersey
and Vail was an experienced machinist
Morse knew nothing
about anything like that but he could
see that somebody who might be able to
tool parts of the Telegraph would be
very helpful for me avail later on in
the century went on to organize a tea is
that any relation no veil if we're
talking about the same veil there are
there lot and there were different veils
they'll die fairly young he done and his
I think in his late 40s or so his wife
Amanda sort of pursued Moore's until his
dying day demanding that he give more
credit to Alfred as part of the inventor
of the Telegraph what what's the overall
importance of all this at one point you
say in the book this could be similar to
a man landing on the moon what he
invented what why would that have been
what were their telephones and were
there anyway how would you communicate
because you yes well it was very very
startling to people I at the time I mean
feel deep people did not understand
electricity to not understand
electromagnetism if you read a newspaper
accounts that they dazzled to think that
this that electricity the most power
which they thought of as lightning they
had no concept really of batteries and
so on somehow Morris was taking
lightning and he was the most powerful
force in nature and he was sending it
through a wire and is staggering to
people once the telegraph really got
going and that that took a long time it
transformed you know business life
social life it had an enormous enormous
effect I mean in in journalism the you
know the idea that you could get news
from the front and the Mexican War or
something and send it up to to
Washington various newspapers started
sending out bureaus in different places
you got the really it's the beginning of
the Associated Press and in business
life you could do all kinds of business
transactions by the telegraph you could
send out an order you could find out
where the order
was socially you know a few if dad was
in Boston and he wasn't feeling well and
you were in New York you got a message
from him saying oh I'm feeling ok and
that was a great relief it transformed
every part of really existence in
America and it worked synergistically I
mean that the railroad was also
developing and big corporations were
coming into being and the the Telegraph
fit in with with that you know and was
energized by those things and those
things were energized by the tolling on
can it be said that because he had he
been befriended the Congress by doing
the painting and then he eventually went
to the Commerce Committee and there's
this fellow you got here in the book
that turned out to be very controversial
f oj smith congressman chairman of the
Commerce Committee what's the story
there
yes well that was a part of Morse's
being accursed was having ever gun
involved with foj Smith who was a
congressman from Maine who Smith was so
impressed by the Telegraph that he gave
up his seat in Congress to work with
Morse and then he first oh he wanted he
wanted to cut of the action before
before he's even willing to leave
Congress characteristically he wanted
some piece of the action before he left
Congress Morris who was you know
extremely shall I say you know a very
honest guy with a lot of integrity which
you wouldn't hear of anything like that
the idea of cheating the government in
some way would be appalling to him in
any case though he saw that Smith was
very well-connected in Washington Smith
knew the business world too as he he
more certainly did not so he and Smith
and a few other people formed a
partnership to advance the Telegraph
from Morse it was a gigantic mistake
because Smith could do almost nothing
honestly and he got Morris involved in
all kinds of very shady kind of schemes
and then he he persecuted Morris
endlessly until there until the end of
his life he was he was a mean everybody
said of him he was a mean Guardian how
much did Congress
the first building of the Telegraph
between Washington and Baltimore my
recollection is Morse went to them I
think for $30,000 to to do the line I
think they gave him 40 actually I think
they gave him another 10,000 for other
expenses he might have and that was the
first building of the targa yes there
was the first public demonstration and
building installation of a telegraph in
America that Baltimore to Washington
long now was this ex congressman Smith
involved in that maybe they have a
percentage of the action from the
beginning Smith was involved in that he
he did some of the contracting for it
and as I recalling one of the contracts
went out to his his brother-in-law I
think this is correct
not a good idea and that there later
came a lot of legal complications out of
that we looked at the man veil and the
man Smith they both had a cut of the
action
how much did Morris own of the company
that was created well this was the
magnetic Telegraph Company
I think Morse at my recollection is I
think more so I'm just about half I
think I think the other partners owned
the other half I have a also photograph
here of a man named Amos Kendall who is
he
Amos Kendall had been the secretary of
whatever it was the post office the
Postmaster General Postmaster General
under Andrew Jackson he had a very large
reputation in the Jackson administration
he wrote speeches for Jackson Jackson
trusted him and he was very very close
with Jackson especially in Jackson's
Warren II you know the bank of United
States kendall also was very interested
in the The Telegraph and he offered to
be Morse's business manager I mean he
understood very well that Morse had no
business sense at all and needed
somebody to manage the business end of
it and offer it to do that it was that
was the best luck that Morse ever had
because Kendall like himself like Morris
Kendall was somebody's real you know
integrity and some feeling and he was a
like Morse very religious guy
and took over this mountain of
Correspondence and bill paying and you
know even getting cedar posts for the
telegraph that was involved in getting
the telegraph started when did Morris's
first wife die
Lucretia yes well there's another that
was sort of the FIR one of the worst
examples there's a cursed life Morse had
gotten a commission to paint a
full-length portrait of the Marquis de
Lafayette I mean to a lot of Americans
Lafayette was George Washington's second
I mean they they love this man and he
they so embodied in him the whole
meaning of 1776 and you know of American
independence Congress paid for a
triumphal I think 50th anniversary visit
of Lafayette to the country where he was
going to tour all the states and the New
York City Council commissioned a voted
to commission a full-length portrait of
Lafayette it was a great Commission of a
very important Commission and it went to
Moores and this is the biggest break yet
by four he had had as a painter and he
started painting lead at the Lafayette
in New York Lafayette and went to to
Washington and he followed Morse
followed him there and was painting in
Washington's delighted to be doing this
commission and for Morse to Lafayette
was what's a great hero and delighted to
be meeting Lafayette while he was
painting he got a letter from home
saying that his wife Lucretia had died
in and she's just apparently some hard
almond that she was a young woman in her
20s she's going into bed and and was
dead that seemed to more so excuse me
the pattern of his life he would be at
some apex of his career painting love
you message would come that his wife Lyz
then we stepped back a little bit she as
I remember she was 25 and he was 33 or
so at the time there's another painting
before we go on that I want to show cuz
it's I have to say it's my favorite in
this whole thing it's this one which is
hard to see we'll get it close-up on it
but what is this called yes that's the
gallery of the Louvre or the Grand
Gallery influitive I would agree that I
think it's my favorite
well one of the things I can't this is
his daughter you say over here um no
that's James Fenimore Cooper and his
daughter oh it's I see but he's in the
center Morris versus in the center
they're giving some instruction and
drawing to Bennett bent over there and
then that's the Mona Lisa right over his
shoulder when did he do this and what
impact did it happened well instead for
now having the heads of 68 members of
Congress we have most of the great best
known paintings in the world reproduced
on on the walls of the Louvre he he
imagines them all being on the wall of
walls of the Louvre this way and they're
wonderful miniature reproductions of
some of the best-known paintings the
Mona Lisa and others not only that but
they've done in perspective so that you
know it's again a very ambitious and
very very complex painting Morris worked
on it it's also for about a year in
Paris when he was studying he did it in
the in the Louvre and attracting a lot
of tension people would stop by and see
what he was painting then there was also
I think was an outbreak of count was a
cholera I was some an outbreak of some
serious illness I think it was cholera
passed through France and people start
they start to carting corpses out of
Paris and people started leaving the
city Mort stayed in the Louvre painting
this really a huge canvas same story he
took it home and went nowhere nobody
came to see it at exhibition he finally
sold it to some collector for relatively
little money you say it's in the Tara
Museum and Chicago Mass have you seen it
in person I don't know I've never seen
it I'm sorry did you ever get any value
of this art today it's an interesting
question you know because his portraits
turn up here and there people bought
they buy them at very reasonable prices
of it's just happened to be speaking
with the poet John Ashbery awhile ago
and he mentioned to me he had been in
some gallery and living in upstate New
York and there was this painting he
liked it very
and the owner told me was by force so he
bought it but there's no vis no vigorous
market forces maybe a senator so he
again he he did this pinning for years
and he got into the telegraph did he
ever paint again after he started the
tundra uh no that was it he even said he
wished he he wanted to just destroy all
of Spain things it not only that the
Telegraph had taken over his interest
but he was just terribly disappointed by
his career what about his children by
his first wife I know Susan he did a he
did a painting called the muse the large
painting at the Metropolitan Museum of
Orden what was his relationship with his
children his wife died
they don't have been married I guess
eight years and they had the three kids
what happened to the kids as he was
moving around it's a very sad part of
Morris's life they were really left on
their own they were farmed out to
relatives they were given to his
brothers or just other families are
willing to look after them they
complained to him too Susan seems to
have been a lovely sort of young girl
she would write to they're very very
touching letters you know she would put
in a little hard in something and say
when this you see remember me Father
please come home and please visit me
haven't seen you in such a long time
very very touching letters but he he
went on he not a good dad I mean and
even worse with his sons he felt it uh
Turley lost contact with his sons his
son Finley had a I assume mental problem
some brain yo some organic brain problem
with that by his first wife yes because
you go into some detail about which
shows again I want to ask you it was so
religious how could he treat a son this
way have it I'll give you an example you
say approaching forty Finley remained
childlike he now permanently lived in
the anti on-deck mountains where he
passed the time gardening and fishing
looked after by Morris's cousins the
Davis's Morris paid for his upkeep but
found one excuse after another not to
write him and asked the Davis's to
explain quote
police say to Finley that I received his
letter
and would have replied but the truth is
I'm so overwhelmed with carers just now
how could he mean how they had a
rectified yeah good question I think
well partly it's you know he told
himself and says some places that you
know he's doing it for them he's on the
road he's painting portraits he's
earning money it's it's for them and so
he can support them and he needs to to
be away from them secondly though you
know he had this a very strong sort of
Calvinist belief or at least he used
this this sort of explanation that you
should not hold your children up as
idols you can't really get too attached
to the things of this world if you make
your wife or your children idols I mean
your real love belongs to God and that's
where all your emotion all your
affection must really be invested this
is the kind of you know explanation he
gave him so I seems pretty transparently
you know some attempt to justify you
found a letter that he wrote his son but
you do you remember where you found it
I don't know I will read it perhaps you
think it is strange this is writing to
Finlay a son that I have not written you
but the truth is that unless I have
something very important to say I am
obliged to employ my pen from morning
till night on matters which require my
whole attention very typical did you
find things for your book that hadn't
been printed yet oh yes there's more so
like to write you know he wrote a
tremendous amount and not only thousands
of letters but he wrote and published a
lot of various tracks he he edited lots
of books the other to the volume of
poetry he wrote a lot of newspaper
articles you know he was a writer too
really very much so so there was an
immense amount of material I was very
happy about that by the way did you have
to find all the photographs of these
paintings in the book or did the
publisher do it for you no I do that did
it cost you money yes did you have to
pay for each one of them yes in some
cases you know
garden outrageous I think the people I
dealt with for these pictures were very
good in fact I didn't give me a hard
time I can I can name a will not people
who are very very tough to deal with can
you tell us some give us some sense of
the you don't have to name the portrait
what what kind of money have to pay to
put them in a book like this well we
could think the Library of Congress this
was selling in the Corcoran you know the
gallery galleries around here
wonderfully they have minimal charges
seventy five dollars maybe or $100 or
something
even though be two three hundred dollars
for a picture you don't have to come out
of your advance or to come out so nobody
came out of all your guns and you
published this book through Knopf you
know how many copies they printed on
your book first no I don't I don't who
is this man Henry O'Reilly in the book
yes this was another of Morse's partners
very interesting guy a tremendously
exuberant a brash guy had come as a
young boy from Ireland him settled in
Rochester New York and he's a real sort
of go-get-'em you know 19th century mid
19th century capitalist he was
tremendously enthusiastic about the
Telegraph and he once he got to be a
partner of horses he had kind of huge
schemes for extending it all over the
country more certainly the sword
extending all over the country but
O'Reilly wanted to do it all at once I
mean it's a guy endless energy and
imagination and you know lots of pep and
lots of vigor so he was already getting
a line up to Canada and Nova Scotia and
out west to st. Louis Morse and Amos
Kendall tried to slow him down I mean
the the thinking that just just can't
work that quickly antagonism developed
and soon Henry O'Reilly became one of
Morris's worst competitors and
antagonists this is what I mean The
Telegraph is a very contentious business
and they at one point Henry O'Reilly was
building a line down to it's down toward
New Orleans and Morris's company was
line down toward I think it was in the
early it's at the same time and they
were working side by side and Morris you
know thought they skies these working
gangs we're gonna have guns of it's
gonna get at each other and still you
have a huge riot it didn't happen that
way but O'Reilly didn't finally have a
success with the Telegraph in fact is
his plans were to a brash and too big
how much was Morris worst at the end of
his life good question he was he was
making more than the President of the
United States his yearly income was more
than Lincoln's let's say income wasn't
his make his thinking was something like
twenty seven thousand dollars a years a
lot of money for the time he had a lot
of money I mean he was a millionaire at
the Smithsonian we took a camera also
were a lot of the the things that he
built and invented are on the walls down
there you can see it there on the screen
can you give us some sense of what we're
looking at here
um let's see
yes those will that's a that's a later
version of the telegraph key I mean this
and a later version of the so called
register it you know the telegraph went
from one version to another here is an
early this is the first version of the
Telegraph and you see that Morse is
built it inside this picture frame this
is some clockwork mechanism that spun
out the paper that got imprinted very
very crude apparatus as you can see this
made the v's on the paper tape it's just
a little stub of a pencil
did he make money out of these this the
instruments also eventually yeah he
licensed you know the production of
Morse instruments and the telegraph spun
off all kinds of other professions I
mean of telegraph businesses and there
were people who just as their own
employment made Telegraph's and what
what year if you remember did the most
of the country have the telegram I think
it was I think during the Civil War they
finally connected up with California and
now he pointed that out you look at his
like of 1863 oars I think there's
another picture in here of a man
Cyrus W feels who is he certainly one of
the most important people in horse's
life Morse had very early the idea that
you could span the Atlantic and that you
be able to send telegraph messages
across the Atlantic a lot of people
thought he was crazy I mean to think
such a thing
Cyrus field didn't think he was crazy
Sarah's field was a very successful
entrepreneur in New York he made a lot
of money in the paper business and he
joined with Morse to build the first
transatlantic telegraph was enormous I
mean for people again at the time that
that was really the moon voyage of the
19th century the building of the
transatlantic Telegraph how often how
long in his life was he active in the
business a field no Morris well active
he was never really active in the
business business you know he stayed out
of the money end of it but all of his
life he was tinkering and trying to make
improvements on the apparatus he got
very active politically during this
civil war
extremely why well more sent lots of
links to the south I mean as his
mother's family the Finley's actually
had come were in South Carolina Morse
had spent two years I think in
Charleston painting his second wife was
from New Orleans and her brother still
lived there he was a sword manufacturer
in New Orleans Morris was very
sympathetic to what he called the
Christian slaveholding south and given
also his his profound cultural
nationalism I mean he really worshipped
the United States and the idea of the
United States when the country started
to fracture in that way it wasn't it was
really a nightmare for him the worst was
happening but he went you know you a lot
of language in here of where he
suggested that the black man and woman
were inferior some strong again some
strong language and I ask you again how
could you feel that way and be so
religious well Morris in fact makes you
know as as some other people did very
elaborate scriptural defenses of slavery
I mean for one thing he tries to show
that
slavery is justified in the in the Bible
I he he wrote several tracks of
defending slavery and in one of them I
remember he tries to show that slavery
is a form of governance like marriage or
child rearing or you know political life
and it really no different from them it
the religions part of it is that you
know as an old sort of old line
Calvinist Morris has this firm
conviction about the fall and the
degeneracy of man and the only way to
keep people in line is through through
government you can't can't give people
freedom in fact one of the things that
startling things that happens during the
Civil War is that he turns his back on
the revolutionary generation this was
quite extraordinary because he he really
DVRed those people but he starts writing
that the Declaration of Independence of
guaranteed a false Liberty you know that
it
the only real Liberty is Liberty under
his Scripture is really Liberty under
God's law is Liberty under governance
oddly Morris's father had been an early
abolitionist but had been for abolition
early on and more it's turns back and
his father too and was aware of that and
said he said he believed that his father
if his father were living at the time of
the civil war his father would share his
pro-slavery views where is this
photograph this is a wonderful study in
the town house that more sport in New
York City I mean once he started making
a lot of money bought this beautiful
house in New York it's still there and
this is a picture of his study in the
town says second wife was 30 years
younger and was deaf she was to
completely couldn't hear a thing how did
he meet her they met at a party upstate
somewhere that that's very fascinating
really as as he mentioned his wife his
son Finley had some kind of organic
brain damage and was also partly deaf he
was very moved to see how some social
gathering how his second wife treated
the the boy
his deaf deafness and oh I don't know is
it you you could think really that his
marrying her was some kind of making up
for his mistreatment of his son is this
Harley deaf son
this photograph aged 72 yes where is he
living the last eight years of his life
well he's mostly living now in New York
City he had a farm in Poughkeepsie and
used to commute to really spend the
summers in there and then the winters in
New York but now he moved entirely to
New York partly because he was too
getting too old to make the trip back
and forth so we get down at the end I
want to show some highlights from the
House of Representatives painting again
which people can see at the Corcoran and
as we mentioned you'll see it on the
screen here often the left those two are
reporters
would a reporter then be a press person
or would it be a recorder of the events
in the house you know I think these are
recorders of events in the house I don't
think they're press people like it could
be rolling although the Washington
newspapers at Leo there were reports
that certainly of doings in Congress at
all those is some of the Supreme Court
members are six in the painting and off
here to the right you can see there at
the very end John Marshall and Joseph
story the man on the far right who is
the youngest Supreme Court justice at
age 32 and then there's a declaration of
independence and this any reason for
that well I think here and this is put
you know a heavily symbolic picture
Morris is trying to show the seriousness
and the the idealism of America by
depicting its its institutions its
documents its its its its seriousness
all right the Indian chief on the right
and his father there the third person
over on the left
why did he put those yes what's
appointee chief there's this father
there on the Left jedidiah morse oh
that's a bit of a story horse's
congregation jedediah's congregation in
Charleston resented all the work he was
doing on geography they thought he
wasn't paying enough time to his pulpit
so they got rid of him I mean they they
fired him and he he
not want to be present at the the formal
ceremony for his dismissal so what he
did was he got a commission from the
government to visit various Indian
communities in central in the Midwest in
any case that's at the pointy chief
Moore's paints here is one of the
members of the community that Jedediah
dealt with in his indian commission this
last kannada in that room john quincy
adams collapsed and then died right off
that room later on but you say in your
book that john quincy adams ended his
painting career yes he felt that the the
painting morris wanted to do above any
other was one of the large murals for
the cat the Dome of the Capitol I mean
John Trumbull had painted one he wanted
to do another one he was not given the
Commission though he tried for the year
of least to get it and he felt that John
Quincy Adams was responsible for his not
getting it
because of some obscure hatred he had
for his father last question do you
think you would have liked this Manik
yeah we had a chance to know what
certainly despises his politics
probably not people generally didn't
didn't like most personally why he was
hard to get along with he was autocratic
he was Moody that's sort of you had a
very large sense of himself extremely
imaginative very intelligent you know
very hard-working
man we haven't even gotten started but
that's what the book is all about and
here is the cover of it called lightning
man Samuel FB Finley Brees Morris our
guest has been Kenneth Silverman and we
thank you very much thank you